well I agree with Brad's point that we
have far too many bureaucrats on the
federal payroll the recent upending of
laws concerning sex and gender have come
from elected and appointed officials
come from the Supreme Court appointed by
presidents it's come from legislators in
Charlotte North Carolina and and all
over the country so it has been from
representatives of people and appointed
officials who uh who have been appointed
by representatives of the people and the
people change their minds that's one of
the features of democracy and so
unfortunately the Supreme Court in 1973
decided that there were some imaginary
right to abortion and this error
persisted for a long time and then 49
years later the court reversed that
decision in 2020
the Supreme Court made an error and
decided to interpret civil rights law
protections for sex as being protections
for sexual orientation and gender
identity which ironically undermines
civil rights protections for sex by
allowing the men to play on the sports
teams and go to the bathrooms and so in
this case I know Brad you keep
suggesting that I want this very narrow
authoritarian totalitarian view I don't
there are all sorts of questions where
I'm happy to leave things pretty open
but on certain issues where
only one side can can establish its
principle in society we have to come to
conclusions and I would come to the
conclusion that has prevailed for all of
human history not the one that cropped
up five seconds ago so I want to push a
little on what pressing on these
questions in this distinctions means for
kind of the stability of our democracy
because it's one thing when losing power
means you know losing a little bit of
ground on some parts of your agenda the
tax rates are set differently more fewer
oil wells are drilled another thing when
laws kind of seesaw wildly between
administrations you know that we have
the kind of the gag rule on abortions
one example of a law that just gets
flipped on and off every time the
administration changes and it feels like
more and more laws are in that All or
Nothing executive order thing it seems
to me that makes every election feel
apocalyptic yes uh we get more of the
flight 93 talk right do you how do you
see a way out or through that right if
people feel losing an election means
losing ground possibly permanently it
doesn't seem we can live alongside each
other at all we've already lost faith in
democracy kind of regardless of where we
draw the line when we're in power this
is such an important point and the
reason that you've seen this kind of
radical polarization where now we go
topsy-turvy every election is every
election that we're able to win for for
that matter sometimes the Democrats rule
for a long time uh the reason for that
is because we no longer have shared
norms and standards and so the very
thing that I am arguing is a solution to
this problem the reason that our norms
and standards have broken down is
because half a century ago leftist
activists decided to upend our standards
and Norms in our culture to say that
having any standards or Norms at all
would be authoritarian and anti-American
and and so what happened was the left
pushed their radical new standards in in
the 1950s the 1940s you could read the
Bible in schools you could not read
pornography in schools today you cannot
read the Bible in schools you can and in
some cases are assigned to read
pornography in schools it's not a battle
of more freedom or less Freedom it's a
bad Battle of what standards are we
going to have what taboos are we going
to have and so what happened in
especially in the 60s is the left
knocked down all of the old standards
they insisted upon their standards in
their place and the conservatives lost
the ability to even speak about
standards to even speak about the good
the true and the Beautiful the common
good the what's true and false and as a
result the left has totally upended
things but I think if we can reassert a
sensible Vision then things will will go
less
for one second then pose a last question
to you too then we'll take questions
from the audience Mr rules do you really
think this is a question of the left
pushing or more of what Aleister
McIntyre describes is just the losing
for many people including conservatives
of a sense of where order comes from
until we don't have a language to speak
together not one side putting forward
new Norms but all sides nearly losing
touch with what gives rise to their
Norms that they learned kind of
habitually from their Community without
learning them from the roots up well I
think you're blaming just one side here
and I don't know that I believe you on
that no I I blame both of those things
but I think one is a consequence of the
other if not entirely a consequence
largely a consequence why are people not
in touch with the basis of order and
Truth might it have something to do with
the fact that left-wing activists booted
the Bible out of schools why is it that
people don't have a solid formation
about the grounding of of our government
and our public life might it have
something to do with the fact that a
judge decided that preachers can no
longer speak about political things that
religion now has to be merely A Private
Matter for the the inner closet of your
own Consciousness rather than a matter
of public life you know to me these are
not separate questions and and I I point
to the left because they have been so
conscious and intentional about this
kind of a strategy and and because
feckless conservatives bought on with
the logic you know there's a line from
William F Buckley Jr who's very
important to this organization uh that I
always come back to from God and man at
Yale and he was quoting a liberal
actually who said it and he said
skepticism has utility only when it
leads to conviction it's nice to have a
big open Society but sometimes people's
minds are so open that their brains fall
out a poem is beautiful because of its
limits and its constraints we are
limited beings and so that we can't be
all things to all people because then
we're not anything to anyone can I just
um
yeah so you say that you want the truth
the freedom to speak the truth and the
good and the Beautiful and everything
else but at the same time I mean you'd
toss up and rip up the First Amendment
to stop drag queens from reading books
to Kids the first amendment doesn't
protect that it does it doesn't the
First Amendment from the beginning of
our country has not protected whole
scores of speech obscenity notably it is
not obscene if it's so first of all you
could ban all sexual performances drag
or not from having minors and i would
support that but to have a fully closed
so you'll Shred the First Amendment no
it's that is obscenity there's a very
clear standard for representative and a
fully clothed person not who is simply
dressed in the attire of the other
gender and wearing makeup reading books
to Children is protected by the First
Amendment for much of our country's
history cross-dressing was illegal
throughout the country including in San
Francisco we had slavery just because we
didn't always live up
but they're not enforced but so I'm
saying just because we had things in the
past doesn't mean they're actually
consistent with our rights I suppose
what you you're saying though Brad is
Michael your view is anti-American and
it's not consistent with the First
Amendment and what I'm pointing to is
the people who wrote the first amendment
the people who ratified the First
Amendment the people who lived in a
country under the First Amendment for
the vast majority of our country's
history they all agreed with me and
people in very recent times have started
to pervert the meaning of the First
Amendment to kind of agree with you the
people who wrote the first amendment
also wrote the alien and seditions acts
amendments for sure but the text of the
Constitution and the principles outlined
are what's important not the
imperfections of the people that drafted
want out of free speech and I know which
side Mr Judd stands on so he's not
getting the question one is that free
speech open discourse is a good in and
of itself uh possibly to avoid coercion
or too large a government that would be
needed to suppress speech but the other
view which is the view I know Mr
knowleshold so he's not going to need to
respond to this one is that the reason
we want freedom of speech is to arrive
at truth in the same way that we want
peer review in scientific journals not
so that there's ultimately a panoply of
voices but so that by hearing everyone
out we wind up with one voice speaking
one thing that is true and I'm curious
for you Mr Palumbo do you see the point
of free speech as an end in itself of
protection from coercion or as a tool to
slowly you know gravitate towards one
thing that is true and free speech is a
tool that gets us there but not the good
where you are pursuing so I definitely
reject the utilitarian view of free
speech is that no I think to some extent
both can co-exist in that I think the
best ideas do win out over time and that
sunlight can be a strong form of
disinfectant but there is utility in and
of itself of letting man be free to say
wrong and false things
about what you like about that because
you've rejected one version of it so
what is the good you see in doing that
that that's the most fundamental aspect
of what it you if you're not free to
speak you're not free to think right
that that is the one of the most
fundamental things about humanity is I
mean I'm going to press one more time
just because for the interest of time
I'm going to do it more briefly than I
know Mr Knowles would uh what is the
good of being free to think
to explore and find the best ideas in
part but also to fulfill The Human
Experience that's what life is is
learning and making your way through the
world and deciding what you believe and
if you're not free to think and you're
not free to speak you're not able to do
that so it's like the idea of for
example
coerced morality isn't really morality
right because if people are doing the
right thing or believing that for
example like everyone's very loyal to uh
Kim Jong-un in North Korea but there's
not actually much value in that loyalty
because it's done at the the threat of
death a lot of a lot of value for Kim
Jong-un all right at this point and you
would like to be Kim Jong-un do you I
don't think I would